it's a lot of fresh start so that kind
of energy is kind of all around the
building but i think in regards to
myself personally uh dan and
alain have
have really empowered me to kind of you
know what do i what do i want what do i
like how do i want to see it how do we
want to do things
and are constantly bouncing things off
me and i'm constantly bouncing things
off them and i think that's been a
healthy relationship and something
that's been uh fun for me to experience
and be a part of
you know guys that you know are really
you know wanting to hear from me and
wanting to hear what i like
i know you're you're more about looking
forward than looking back but how
different is that than maybe what you
were used to in terms of the the
empowerment and you know is it is it to
a greater degree maybe then
i'm not saying that in any in any uh
regard to previous uh experiences it's
it's not um i'm not saying it like that
i'm saying it's it's it's been great
oh he had the he had the touch of the
face high above the eyebrow that's when
it's really bad when you go above the
eyebrow so look he was micromanaged by
sean mcvay it's okay we know it that's
the way it is right mcvay's offense it's
not jared goff's offense and as the
lions figure out how best to run their
offense anthony lynn is is seeking input
from jared goff and dan campbell is
endorsing that approach whether or not
it works is a different issue hey it
sure it feels great for jared goff to be
empowered he's still gonna go out and
play and we've seen enough and more
importantly the rams saw enough
from jared goff
to say we gotta get this guy the hell
out of here and before that we gotta get
this guy the hell off the field for john
wolfe exactly so that tells us all we
need to know about where jared goff
currently is or at least where he was as
at the end of the 2020 season yeah and
no doubt about it and to me
it's about what he does on the field
playing wise like i i don't like
i i don't doubt that he's being
empowered within that offense you know
schematically and things like that yeah
he was micromanaged to by sean mcvay
like you're talking about but still had
a lot on his plate that he had to
organize at the line of scrimmage and
all the quick tempo plays and everything
like that to where he's going to have a
good knowledge of how to run an offense
mcvays taught him hey you know i like to
run this play against this look and if
they do this look let's audible to that
look or run to this play where this side
whatever that may be and that's where i
think the value of jared goff can be for
dan campbell and anthony lin he
certainly can help them piece together
the offense to where
yeah it fits best for the lions it fits
best fits best for jared goff but like
that's not the stuff you worry about
with jared goff to your point it's like
what we see on the field it's bad pocket
awareness it's lack of plays with your
legs i mean the highlights we just
showed right there i mean there were two
touchdown passes the ball barely spins
and it's a wobbler the ball's all over
the place at times so it's those things
that got to improve i know he knows what
play to check to and knows how to call
call a play in the huddle uh i don't i
don't doubt that part of his game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports